oh
là là que j'ai sonné
moi je n'ai même pas fermé l'oeil de la
nuit avec cette chaleur
n'ont plus à manger j'ai travaillé j'ai
fait mes comptes toute la nuit
on his
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en mes amis quelle fatigue j'ai pas
fermé l'oeil de la nuit et casimir kings
les jurés vous êtes sait-on ligue 2 nous
apporte au milieu de l'île ben oui c'est
bien mon lit où il ne s'agit pas d'un
souffleur 1 j'ai pris mes précautions
pour la nuit prochaine mais casimir où
veux-tu en veulent in iraq et bien je
vais dormir à la belle étoile
j'aurais moins chaud que dans ma chambre
casimir tu n'as pas fait ton lit smati
non pourquoi je fais jamais nous casimir
il faut faire son lit tous les matins
ans le faut à quoi ça sert de faire son
lit le matin puisque on leur en effet le
soir on se couche à enfin tu fais ton
lit tous les jours mais bien sûr c'est
plus prompte et c'est plus un mais trois
ans et trois mois mais moi aussi casimir
dans un lit bien fait ça on est beaucoup
mieux
n'avait pas tes pieds sur mon lit au
partant partant à l'effet tu mens une
démonstration alors bon si tu le
regardes en larmes enlève tout
inclus les petits plis soit vous voilà
ça c'était le drap des dessous
maintenant le dra-10 dessus bien voilà
on dirait que vous avez travaillé dans
un grand hôtel tous travaux toucheront
voilà au bord de bien vous
au pied impeccable
quelques la cellule anti revient bien
voilà un événement
la couverture elle style d'avoir casimir
elle est bien chaude
bien bien bien ensuite à la même chose
il attend en beauté rien les côtés aussi
lit côté on renonce ouais voilà ça y est
attendez bordelais côté et la rai et
pour le thème bien par enfant j'allais
lui faire mal
voilà quelques mois et bien moi je vous
conseille de venir faire mon lit tous
les matins et des bras casimir comme
c'est agréable de dormir dans un lit
bien c'est la bombe enfin pour commencer
j'enlève l'oreiller pourquoi pourquoi
parce que je n'aime pas dormir avec un
oreiller d'abord parce que j'ai pas
d'oreilles et ensuite c'est bien
meilleur pour mon épine dorsale aléas
pas d'oreiller mieux qui a failli massot
mais bon la couverture la couverture en
laine et beaucoup de choses pour l'été
enfin casino remis à chaque écoute mais
plus tu vas m'étouffer casimir en fait
je n'ai pas besoin non plus de drague
monsieur mais attends attends je vais
m'en occuper lwama moi si tu veux courir
après tout ça je me demande maintenant
ce que tu peux bien tiré il n'y a plus
rien à retirer mais maintenant on peut
rajouter ne rajouter quoi eh bien il me
faut une petite tape nuit pour poser mon
bol de gloubiboulga alors parce que
lorsque je me réveille la nuit commence
toujours un petit gloubiboulga quand
j'ai accru l'estomac tu sais quasi mais
il vaut mieux ne pas prendre son petit
déjeuner au lit ça ça fait des tâches et
des miettes dedans enfin casimir prends
ma chaise elle te servira cette nuit
table de nuit par un gloubi mais là
quand mais pour l'est pour la et
moustiques alors qu'elle est m'enfin là
la nuit en été il y à des moustiques
alors tu es tu veux que je t'apporte une
moustiquaire ses seins ou stockés à
une moustiquaire ou une mouche
antiquaires casimir une moustiquaire
moustiquaires d'accord si tu veux
tu en as une dot au kiosque julie a oui
c'est vrai leur petite ville américaine
pour monsieur casimir web installera
tout à l'heure bon bah oui mais
maintenant il me faut niang de chemin
une lampe de chevet bon j'irai aussi je
marierai jamais si tu as peur l'année
alors tiens voilà une très jolie lampe
de chevet
eh bien voilà mais pour lire alors je
regrette délivrant rigolo pour lire
avant de m'endormir avoir rigolo hui vos
tables tiens voilà bon ils sont rigolos
pas rigolo
mais la 40e alors une carafe d'eau
maintenant j 20 15 energy vient franchin
bien fraîche une carafe d'eau bien
fraîche pour qu'elle varie entre
l'académie retient il ouvert alors je
vais pas boire au boulot quand même hein
c'est vrai
[Musique]
voilà vert je me demande si je n'ai rien
oublié non tu n'as rien vu rien du tout
casimir si avec tout ça d'une passe pas
une excellente nuit ça ne sera vraiment
pas de notre faute je vous assure il me
semble pourtant que j'ai oublié quelque
chose
encore
ça y est j'y suis mais oui je suis
invitée chez mon oncle archibald pour
deux jours et je vais dormir chez lui ce
soir alors comme je ne serais pas là
vous pouvez vraiment rangé tout ça parce
que ça fait très désordre
[Musique]